over the weekend major league baseball
the national pastime decided that they
would become just the democratic pastime
they decided they were going to cancel
the all-star game in georgia
this cancellation was based on overt
democratic lies
parroted and forwarded by an
establishment media that are partisan
hacks they are partisan activist liars
this is what they do for a living now
i've been hesitant to use the phrase
enemy of the people because it's a
stalinist phrase that suggests that
people should go to jail or that people
bad things should happen to people
but let me just say that the media are
the enemies of the truth the
establishment media are just partisan
hacks at this point
they have allowed joe biden and the
biden administration to simply lie
about the content of this georgia voter
law which is more liberal
with regard to early voting than laws in
places like new jersey
its voter id requirement is utterly
uncontroversial it did not dismantle
all ballot drop boxes or anything like
that ballot drop boxes are a new thing
that were sort of created for the
pandemic it limited the number of those
it didn't get rid of all of them
it expanded in many ways the voting
hours in georgia
this is an extraordinarily mild law in
georgia but that's not what you'd get if
you read your mainstream media if you
read your establishment media what you
would get
is that this was a jim crow attempt to
stop black people from voting that was a
lie
a lie a lie it was a lie all the way
through and joe biden kept saying jim
crow
over and over and over and nobody in the
media saw fitz to fact check that
statement
they would fact-check very specific
statements that joe biden made on
occasion so you get the washington post
giving joe biden four pinocchios for
suggesting that the georgia bill limited
voting hours but
would they overall rate his statement
that this was like a jim crow voting law
of course not
of course not even though it is overtly
a lie you have to be so
unbelievably ignorant and stupid to
believe that this georgia law has
anything to do
with jim crow and yet if you polled
americans i would bet money that half of
americans think that this is jim crow
racism this georgia voter law which
again
is more liberal than delaware state
voting law apparently
so here's what happened joe biden and
the biden administration
and his partners in the media because
that's what they are they are not
objective in any way
they are simply propagandas on behalf of
the democratic party
this partisan hack group decided to push
that lie and not just push that lie
then in activist fashion to try and
pressure private corporations into
pressuring
public bodies like the georgia state
legislature or like the governor of
georgia
so they're trying to mobilize
corporations to do their dirty work for
them they don't have control
of the deliverers of power in georgia so
instead what they're going to do is
they're going to try and get private
corporations
to pressure all these public bodies into
doing what they want now there's a
certain irony to this
members of the left are constantly
saying corporations they shouldn't be
donating money in politics they
shouldn't be in politics with these
corporations with their with their
corporate money
influencing politics and then at the
exact same time they will demand that
these corporations
actively use their businesses right not
just
their funds their businesses themselves
they should change how they do business
in order to punish republican states and
so
they put a lot of pressure on major
league baseball joe biden went on espn
and he overtly called
for major league baseball to remove the
all-star game from georgia and major
league baseball and rob manfred who's an
abject coward
he's a pathetic abject coward he's a
yellow-bellied coward
that that cowardly ridiculous person
decided you know what that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna pull the all-star
game
from georgia and this follows in the
footsteps of other sports that have done
similar things we saw the ncaa pull
basketball games
from north carolina after a bill that
would have protected
women's bathrooms in charlotte we saw
that there were sports leagues that
attempted to
target arizona in the aftermath of jan
brewer former governor of arizona
pushing the idea that that arizona is
going to enforce immigration law on a
state level
this is nothing new it's just the latest
iteration and it's the most ridiculous
iteration because it is based
on just complete utter lies
again the georgia law is not offensive
for anyone who's actually looked at the
georgia law
the lies about this this bill are insane
the lie that you can't drink water
or be given water if you're 150 feet
from a polling place no you can't have a
partisan activist
bring you water but there are poll
workers there and they will bring you
water you can bring water yourself you
can have a friend go get your water
this is the same law that applies in a
bevy of states but that's not what you
heard
about this law is it what you heard from
stacey abrams who is a liar and joe
biden who is a liar and the media who
are liars is that this is a jim crow
voting tactic designed to stop
black people from voting again an overt
lie
and major league baseball decided to
mirror that lie
okay again these lies were consistent
over and over and the media just
repeated them
the the washington post reported abram's
abram's actually claimed this is a claim
from stacey abrams again the greatest
politician in american history stacey
abrams she claimed
quote that the georgia gop traded
economic opportunity for suppression
so this was suppression of the vote
okay the washington post by the way did
report in a fact check that experts
consulted by the newspaper said the net
effect was to expand the opportunities
to vote for most georgians
not limit them but that didn't stop the
washington post from simply
repeating ad nauseam joe biden's lines
about how this was jim crow racism
biden said that he would strongly
support the league boycotting the city
over the law that was passed by
democratically elected officials
according to daily wire
georgia governor brian kemp fought back
against all this he said there's no way
we should apologize for this law are you
guys insane there's nothing wrong with
the law
there were mechanical issues that needed
to be fixed
there were reasons to try to figure out
a better way
a more accessible way in a more secure
way
for us to hold elections and there is
nothing wrong with that
we shouldn't apologize for wanting to
make it easy to vote
and hard to cheat and maybe there's an
argument for
boycotts and protests and moving
all-star games
but that is not what happened what
happened was
georgia is going to have secure
very accessible and fair elections in
the future in this state
kemp also went ahead and slammed joe
biden who of course had lied about the
georgia law over and over and over again
it certainly doesn't help when you have
the president of the united states
saying that
and nobody in the national media at
least in the mainstream media will even
ask for a correction when he simply lies
gets a four pinocchios of all people
of all places from the washington post i
mean that should tell you right there
he's not being truthful he continues to
lie and mislead about what the bill does
so how exactly did this boycott come
about by the mlb
how exactly did major league baseball
america's national pastime decide that
they are simply going to inject
themselves
into american politics on the state
level and punish states on the basis of
democratic lies how did this happen
here's i'll give you that story in just
one second because it truly is
incredible it shows you
how a small and transient group of
people along with the media pushing from
the outside in activist fashion
can make this stuff happen it really is
an amazing amazing thing
how did all of this materialize it
materialized because just like
all corporate blowhardism basically you
have a small and transition group of
people
inside a corporation that have to be
very large
they just to be very loud and very
intransigent and they work an inside
outside game with the media
they push from the inside the small and
transient group of folks and then you
have the media
pretending that this represents a broad
majority inside the corporation
and threatening that corporation with
outside action if they refuse
to acknowledge what these wokesters
inside their own halls
want right this is how you get woca cola
you get wokacola because you have
a very small percentage of employees at
woca cola
20 of the employees and they decide that
they don't like the georgia law and then
you have the media on the outside
yelling at coke
and you have all of the heads of coke
going well you know does it really
matter if we like just say we don't like
the georgia law is that really that big
a deal we'll just put out a statement
saying we don't like it and then they'll
leave us alone
okay this is what happened with the mlb
with major league baseball
and again on a personal level i don't
have a lot of brand investments right i
don't care if i don't have to if i don't
drink coke it doesn't make any
difference to me i drink coke in the
first place i'm not a soda person
but i do care about major league
baseball i'm an enormous baseball fan
i've been an enormous baseball fan my
entire life my father and i wrote a
full-on book about the 2005 chicago
white sox championship season
we went through literally every game
that season that's how big a baseball
fan i am
i'm a huge huge baseball fan i grew up
with it it's a part of sort of the
lifeblood
of the country and seeing that lifeblood
poisoned with the politics of wokeness
is deeply disturbing
it's disturbing on a number of levels
first they're taking things that we all
should be able to share together and
they're wreck and they're wrecking them
they're politicizing them
but just as importantly they're taking
cherished
aspects of american culture and they are
turning them to politics
and once you do that there's nothing we
share they're making it
the left is making it so there's
literally nothing we share we can't
share a baseball game without getting
political we can't pick a razor brand
without getting political
everything is political now and this is
the way they want it this is why when
you hear some conservatives say why are
you so worried about the culture wars
why don't you just worry about the
spending i care about the spending i do
i care about joe biden's crappy bills
we'll get
to that but i care much more deeply
about culture because culture is
upstream of politics
a culture that refuses to acknowledge
dissent as legitimate
political diversity a culture that says
you can't work at this corporation
because you voted for trump or that you
can't
you can't have an all-star game in your
state if you voted the way we don't like
that culture is not destined to remain
that is a culture that is destined to
break down
to polarize and then to just collapse in
on itself like a dying star and that's
what we're seeing in the united
states right now how exactly did major
league baseball again
a coalition of teams with an anti-trust
exemption that should be removed now
how did that coalition of teams with
teams all over the united states
including in red
areas okay georgia despite the fact that
it just elected two blue senators
in a in a bizarre special election
it still is a red state it has a red
legislature it has a red governor
and now after this is going to have two
red senators next time it comes up how
exactly
did this league decide that it was time
to just alienate half of its fan base
minimum half of its fan base
commissioner rob manfred according to
espn made the decision to move the
all-star game in events
along with the amateur draft from
atlanta after discussions with
individual big leaguers and the players
alliance
an organization of black players formed
after the death of george floyd
last year this all came together rather
quickly said chicago cubs outfielder
jason hayward who is black
we had i think a day left in spring
training the players alliance we
gathered and got as many people as we
could on a call
it was probably less than 50 guys on
there out of the 100 or whatever
we had our conversation we knew how we
felt about it we wanted to make sure i
think that regardless of what happened
the decision was made
and that we were there to do what we
could in atlanta so number one they
promulgated a lie that the georgia voter
law was about voter suppression it was
not and that was based on
a larger lie that democrats were pushing
over the course of the last few years
which is every time they lost an
election it was about suppression of the
black vote it was a lie
it's been a lie it continues to be a lie
this has nothing to do with jim crow
has nothing to do with race and it's
disgusting i mean really repulsive that
the media
parroted that lie and treated it as
legitimate over and over and over
but for our purposes it's just as
important to see that the mlb
shifted its entire stance and removed
according to
the cobb county officials in georgia 100
100 million dollars in revenue from cobb
county
because 45 players in mlb decided to
write a letter rob manfred
i mean that's unbelievable according to
daily wire
georgia county that voted for biden will
lose 100 million dollars
over the mlb relocating the game a
hundred million dollars is removed from
the local economy people lose their jobs
because jason hayward who makes millions
of dollars for being an overrated
baseball player
and some 40 other players decided that
it was deeply necessary
for the mlb to move its all-star game
and rob manfred because he's a coward
decided to go along with it but was it
really about those players
was it really it wasn't only about those
players it was certainly partially about
those players
because those players were very loud and
they were shouting about racial justice
even though again this had nothing to do
with race and it was based on a lie
but it was about this intransigent woke
minority inside
mlb combined with a media that was
actively pushing this stuff
actively pushing this stuff and when i
say actively pushing this stuff
let me give you a an example of just how
actively they were pushing this stuff in
just one second because
this is an ins it it shows what the
media are they're an activist propaganda
group on behalf of the democratic party
that's all they are they deserve no more
respect than the normal press release
that you get
from the dnc or from the dnc or from the
the democratic
national campaign committee or from
media matters
they're just an activist group they're a
propaganda outlet they are the pravda of
the democratic party
here is the proof that your media are
just a bag of flaming garbage who need
to be torn down
okay cbs new they're just activists cbs
because it's mlb didn't shift just
because of these woke players these 45
woke players or whomever
by the way how many total mlb players
total number
of mlb players right now is
something like a thousand there are a
thousand players on opening day rosters
of the mlb
over a thousand less than 50 players
made the mlb move that
according to espn that's how little the
intransigent minority
has to be in order to reshape the entire
industry it's unreal it's
and that only happens because the media
are who the media are because what do
the media do
what the media do is they then call up
mlb's advertisers
they call up woca cola and they say you
guys advertise with mlb
you just said that you came out against
the georgia bill but i see that you're
advertising
with the mlb who's having their all-star
game in georgia why would you do that
and then woca-cola calls up mlb and they
say you know what it's real awkward for
us why don't you move the all-star game
that's how this little pathetic game
works and the media are in on it
when the media call up coca-cola for
comment they're not calling them for
comment
they're demanding action from coca-cola
because the threat is we are now going
to run a headline
saying that coca-cola is a bunch of
hypocrites this is why number one these
corporations should never give an inch
because once the inch is given they are
done as the minute you feed a toe to the
alligator the rest of you is gone
okay this is the this is the the robert
shaw seen in jaws the minute you're
sliding down that deck and you're trying
to fend off the shark with your feet
pretty soon you're gonna find your torso
in its mouth that is what's happening to
all of these corporations
right now so how does he this is the
perfect proof
cbs put out a headline over the weekend
here was the headline it was friday
night
quote three ways companies can help
fight georgia's restrictive new voting
law
does that sound like news to you that
was not in their opinion section that
was not
there was no opinion tag or disclaimer
on the article
three ways companies can help fight
georgia's restrictive new voting law
so number one a few problems one it is
not a restrictive new voting law it
expands voting
expands it two so that's just a lie two
that is a perfectly activist headline
you would see that
from the democratic national committee
you would see that at stacy abrams's
website
three ways companies can help fight
right the implication being if you don't
then you're in favor of georgia's evil
restrictive new voting law
the media are activists if you give them
an iota of respect
it is because you're being a dum-dum
they deserve none of your respect this
doesn't mean
don't watch what they say and then don't
fact-check it you should fact-check it
but if you take what they say at face
value it's because you're a
there's no way that you should be
watching cbs news and taking it at face
value
there's just no way to do it and it's
just mirroring democratic party
priorities that's all they do that's
their actual agenda
why because if the media actually
reported what's going on with mlb
it would be perfectly obvious how
hypocritical mlb is
as fox news reported it turns out that
major league baseball
is protesting that georgia voting law
meanwhile they have bolstered ties with
the communist party-backed chinese
company that cracked down on an nba
executive who
supported the pro-democracy move in hong
kong
the mlb signed a deal with 10 cent on
wednesday it's one of china's largest
tech companies
it's one of the chinese firms that
briefly dropped nba games in 2019
after former houston rockets general
manager daryl mori publicly voiced
support for pro-democracy protesters
facing a beijing backed crackdown in
hong kong
as always it turns out that these sports
teams it's all about the money it's not
about how they are
principled opponents of the georgia
voting law it's because they wish to
avoid
the scrutiny of the media who don't care
at all that all these corporations are
doing business
with the worst people on earth companies
that are sponsored
by the repressive and tyrannical chinese
government
it's just it's an incredible incredible
that headline my goodness cbs news
eventually pulled it
but the fact that it was even up just
demonstrates where your media are
and they are garbage by the way speaking
of hypocrisy
remember joe biden called for mlb to
move the all-star game
right that's the real reason this
happened joe biden called for it stacey
abrams didn't call for it but basically
said that the georgia voting laws jim
crow
which which promulgated the myth the
media pushed it
and then you had just enough people
inside mlb yelling about it that rob
manfred
wimped out because that's what he was
going to do meanwhile jen sackey
can't answer a very simple question why
is it that you're saying company should
boycott georgia but you
the president of the united states the
white house you are not calling for the
united states
to boycott the olympics in china which
it turns out is
you want to know a country that has
really restricted voting laws like super
restricted voting laws not about like
people who are partisan giving water
bottles to people 150
paces from the voting place but you know
people being
sent to detention camps if they vote the
wrong way you know
china bad voting laws over there and yet
strangely joe biden seems perfectly
willing to have an olympics in china
when can we expect a final determination
from the president
about the united states participating in
the beijing olympics given that he said
the chinese president doesn't have a
democratic bone in his body
well i think the u.s olympic committee
uh would play a big role in uh
in on major league baseball here in the
united states he actually
didn't i i think i don't know if you
heard the the answer the question the
answer that happened a few minutes ago
where we addressed this and i
answered the question so uh and i give a
little more context but maybe you
weren't paying attention to that part oh
no you're just a liar you're just a liar
you're fine
with the united states doing the beijing
olympics because you don't care if china
represses its own people
but you do care about lying about
georgia's that you can presumably win a
bigger share of the black vote by lying
to black voters that jim crow is coming
for them
it's not a shock that the same joe biden
claimed that mitt romney wanted to put
black people back in chains is claiming
that a law that expands voting access in
georgia
actually restricts it to hurt black
people they're just damned liars and the
media repeated their repeat of full
scale
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content